he didn't like your dogs your dogs were
poisoned on Friday night it seems
possible that you found out that he
poisoned them and and took revenge the
idea that my neighbors may have done it
did in fact it currently one of them and
then the first one was a doctor next
door because he lives closest to me Greg
lives way down the beach and I was even
surprised he could even hear my dogs um
but both of these vote Gregg and the
doctor had dogs love dogs a dog owner a
dog lover is not going to poison anybody
sog under any circumstances now maybe
they've poisoned me but not my dogs as
to your speculations of what might have
happened to him I do not have a clue the
only information I have about him is
what you have told me and what I think I
think cash or facility told me I had no
idea that that he was he was shot
execution-style I heard some things were
missing you're the one who told me was a
9-millimeter shell yeah Paulino had no
speculation other than the first thing I
thought about was oh my god he's wiping
I'm a white man someone's you know the
government's finally decided to off me
they got the wrong white man since we're
so we know we live almost next door and
that actually went in my mind and
actually scared me for quite a while why
do you think the government is target on
you well because the number one I I'm
one of the first foreigners to live here
that actually is you know the bumped up
against the government and then I have
access to to the person and can head for
a long time and that's my only my only
weapon really and so I talk and I tell
the truth and it's it's a very negative
light I mean for example in this country
now they can try you without a jury
meaning you can be charged first of all
they can hold her for 30 days without
even charging then you can be charts and
the prime minister or cabinet minister
can choose an appropriate judge to judge
you and the judge can judge you any way
you wish is no jury no due process
this is where we stand and this is
what's going to happen to me by the way
when I'm caught there i will be held
without charges if I survived the 30
days which I doubt very strongly lots of
people do you know die in prison here
from in a strangle on their own vomit
hanging themselves because they're too
miserable getting beaten to death by
fellow inmates or a variety of other
things and then of course is not the
government's fault while you know you
did wrong you got arrested and something
happened to it but if I do survive that
30 days and some judge we go let your
guilty period if it's inevitable that
they will get you why not get a lawyer
and turn yourself in okay the last I
profile person to turn himself in was
shot in fact in police custody his name
was Arthur Young his handcuffs retired
but he's had his hands cuffed behind
this back and they shot it